we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p last week i
had an interview with former senator and
twenty twenty Democratic presidential
candidate Mike Gravel
and we talked about his beliefs around
9/11 and conspiracy theories and it
really activated a lot of conspiracy
theorists in our audience including this
one who called in saying I am one of
them I am one of them take a listen to
this I just want like Carl let you know
that I thought your umbrella disrespects
respectful to Senator Ravel and your
attitude was poor was not like a
journalist and I won't be watching
anymore I understand where you're coming
from now you're one of them you're one
of these people yeah I think you're
you're trying to cover up what was done
that day piece of crap right yeah I'm
trying to cover up the truth about what
happened on 9/11 because what why is it
that I would do that so once again
listen I mean the term journalist I'm
not a journalist in the sense that I'm a
reporter who just asks questions and
doesn't give my opinion this is an
opinion show okay there are many
programs that are not opinion shows
there are many programs that our opinion
shows but pretend not to be and maybe
you're getting tricked by some of those
we've talked about that as a media
literacy issue but this is a program
where I give my opinion you can disagree
with my opinion absolutely you are free
to never watch this program again or
listen to this program again but I am
one of them is an extraordinarily
conspiratorial allegation and absent any
evidence probably should drop it but if
you have some way to defend the claim
that I am quote
that I know is false but have some kind
of reason to spread anyway give me some
evidence give me some evidence that
that's going on and I will gladly
address it on the program we have a
great bonus show for you today
turmoil continues to deepen within the
National Rifle Association as president
Oliver North is ousted the University of
Virginia basketball
is declining to visit the white house
after winning a championship would they
have done the same if President Obama
was still president think we know the
answer to that but we will discuss on
the bonus show and lastly a father has
been arrested after accidentally
shooting their six-year-old child with
during a gun safety lesson and we're
going to talk about what some call
accidental shootings I prefer to call
them negligent unintended discharges of
a firearm we will talk about all of that
and more on today's bonus show don't
miss it become a member become a patron
to get instant access